Kris Jenner worries her six
grandchildren will be bullied we decided
you know to really let it all hang out
when we started our show the star and
executive producer of Keeping Up with
the Kardashians opens up as part of a
new hollywood reporter roundtable
celebrating unscripted series quote it's
my grandchildren who i worry about
because i have six of them the oldest
just turned seven and my youngest is six
months old and they don't have a choice
and I worry I do because it is such a
bullying environment but the family
matriarch says her kids Kourtney Kim
khloé Rob Kendall and Kylie have
developed their own thick skin since the
show first premiered ten years ago Kim
leads the pack she's queen of thick skin
the 61 year old reveals that she warned
the family about the haters from the
get-go we decided as a family if we're
gonna do this just show everything with
that sort of philosophy and attitude I
told the kids don't get on the internet
now it's so amplified and so heightened
to this level of like haters are going
to hate and all that and you just expect
it now for the trolls to be all over the
internet just criticizing every last
thing you do but it isn't all hate
everybody can relate to somebody in my
family whether you're 7 or you're 107
and I think people just got emotionally
attached and invested I mean it's like
the things that go on I couldn't make
this stuff up
[Music]